before we dive in I went to the UK
recently and I took all this footage and
I have no idea what the hell to do with
all of it so I'm just gonna let that
play as I'm talking about this stuff so
I wanted to address a topic that so many
of you guys message me with I see it in
the comments section all the time
comments like I feel like every day I
live the same day I want more than
anything to be motivated but it just
feels like no matter what I do nothing
works I feel so stuck so maybe you're in
that situation maybe you watch
self-improvement content like this
hoping for an aha moment you know the
Special Sauce the secret mindset that'll
Propel you out of the current life that
you live the mindset that will make
everything make sense but here's the
thing instead of waiting for an aha
moment you can be doing something a lot
simpler there's an easier way to escape
the mental patterns you've imprisoned
yourself into and that is to go outside
and I know that probably sounds super
condescending go outside how is that
going to solve my financial problems
make me eat healthier or stop being
depressed but here's the thing yes I
mean literally go outside we'll talk
about that in a second but I mean go
outside in every sense of the word
because so many of us don't realize just
how inside we've become we're living
inside our house inside our room inside
our heads inside ourselves it all just
feeds into each other and then we feel
trapped and it happens so gradually and
so naturally we just sort of wake up one
day and we ask ourselves how come my
life feels so small I remember when I
was a kid there's new sights and sounds
and people to meet things to experience
but now it just feels like my life is
Tiny there's nothing new Under the Sun
and that's because we've become inside
how did this happen see the more time we
spend being inside our house inside our
car on our phone browsing social media
watching YouTube videos on your laptop
and the less time we spend as part of a
community being a person in the world
exposing ourselves to sunlight and
external social scrutiny we become
isolated when our mind isn't focused
outwards and instead completely inwards
it's like we become toxically
self-conscious and not self-conscious
like oh do these genes make me look fat
but more like we become hyper aware of
our own existence our thoughts become
Extremely Loud we start to obsess about
our own thoughts and our own ruminations
and our brain needs variety you know a
healthy mind goes to different places
and sees different things engages in
unique challenges talks with different
people so what do we do about it you
know not all of us can just quit our
jobs and start eating sushi most of us
are constrained we're all pretty short
in the freedom Department we can't just
do whatever we want most most of us have
to go to a job whether we feel like it
or not we have to make money to support
ourselves and our family so we can pay
rent so if that's you are you doomed
obviously not why would I make this
video and just tell you you're doomed
you probably know instinctively that
there is an answer there is a way to
break out of this pattern and that's why
I'm saying go outside because sometimes
the most complicated problems have the
simplest Solutions if you're feeling
stuck and you're looking for answers and
you want new ideas and you want to
change things up then the very first
thing you should do is to leave your
house go on a walk to somewhere you
haven't gone before by physically going
somewhere different and taking in the
surroundings I guarantee you you will
think thoughts you haven't thought
before because as it stands if you've
been doing the same thing every day you
will think the same thoughts that you
think every day because how else are you
going to get a new thought like what's
in your brain is already in there so
when something bubbles up from your
subconscious it's not going to feel very
new you because it was in there the
whole time we don't think ourselves into
new ways of living we live ourselves
into new ways of thinking just by doing
that often going for a walk and
experiencing something new you'll see
your problems from A New Perspective
you'll gain some distance from your
problems because from a distance even
the biggest problems can seem small even
the most complicated scenarios can start
to gain some Simplicity and speaking of
thinking new thoughts limit your time on
YouTube and Instagram and Tick Tock
because these algorithmically dependent
platforms are the antithesis of thinking
new thoughts these apps are literally
designed to keep you watching the same
content constantly like anybody who
spends any time on YouTube has the exact
same complaint they're like man I hate
my YouTube homepage there's like three
channels on here where's the entire rest
of the internet like it's wild my own
YouTube homepage is like three types of
videos It's like hockey highlights rust
gameplay a and Chiropractic adjustment
compilations like one day in the entire
year your friend could be like oh check
out this cool golf video you should
watch this funny golf video so you look
it up and then you're like okay that was
kind of funny I watched most of that and
then for the rest of your life your
recommended golf content you get sucked
into this whole like golf phase so it's
like you get trapped into these like
very sticky topics you get trapped into
this like mathematical algorithm
and your world shrinks and shrinks and
shrinks until you're thinking the same
thoughts and watching the same things
for the rest of your life anyways the
world is huge there are so many thoughts
to be thought there are so many things
to be thunk so many things to experience
so many places to go there are answers
to your problems your giant complicated
problems might actually have very simple
Solutions but maybe you just can't see
them because you're right in the middle
of it so go somewhere new physically go
experience something new 15 minutes 20
minutes go walk somewhere new and while
you're out there being a person in the
world ask yourself how can I be
motivated by incentivized by and look
forward to the things in my life what
problems do I have that if I were to
solve them my life would be more
exciting I wouldn't need to escape all
the time and if you feel like you're
just in this phase of escaping from Life
playing lots of video games being on
your phone a lot watching Netflix ask
yourself if I keep escaping from reality
how do I create a reality I don't want
to escape from how can I help myself
make my life more exciting and more
hopeful hopefully this video gives you
some perspective and gives you something
to think about because personally in my
own life just gaining some distance from
my problems adds a level of clarity that
has been desperately needed thanks for
watching
a big thank you to athletic greens for
sponsoring this video you guys already
know that ag1 is my favorite supplement
and that's because there's basically no
competing with how easy and simple it is
to drink as well as how good it is for
you and how good it makes me feel
throughout the day packed with over 75
vitamins minerals Whole Food sourced
superfoods and adaptogens in every
single scoop ag1 gives your body
everything it needs to help you feel
focused and energized throughout the day
and unlike so many basic multivitamins
ag1 has a high degree of bioavailability
which means that your body can actually
absorb it so it can use it in the most
effective way possible so if you're
interested in joining me in this simple
daily habit that I've been doing for
about two years now then if you use my
link in the description below you'll
also get a year's supply of the vitamin
D3 and K2 complex which I also have
every single morning as as well as five
ag-1 travel packs with your first
purchase so click that link to take
advantage of that amazing offer and
thanks again to athletic greens for
sponsoring this video increase friction
in the way of watching YouTube content
increase friction in the way of watching
or browsing social media
and while you're in the cave because you
have to get dressed and clean up after
work
don't design your cave in a way
that just keeps you in it that keeps you
stuck in it
so many people just buy bigger TVs
bigger iPhone screens they invest in
better hardware for their gaming PC they
get a comfier couch they find ways to
make being inside the cave as appealing
and as comfortable and as pleasurable as
possible
but then you have to think about instead
incentive structures
right like are you interested in
motivated by and incentivized by the
things in your life
or are you motivated by increasing the
quality of your escapes
are you motivated by buying a bigger TV
so you can watch more YouTube content
that you don't give a [__] about really
and it makes you feel terrible
or are you focusing on
and giving air time to the types of
thoughts that make the rest of your life
better you know that help you be a
person in the world to help you be a
character that people know
you know that's why I say things like
let people know your name
because even something as simple as that
phrase
let people know your name
it just implies like yeah be somebody
who people know and think about and like
you know they they know your character
and a lot of the time what you find is
when you're part of these sub
communities when you go to choir
practice when you go to drop in hockey
when you go to this book group that you
never go to or where you go to this
young adults group at your church or
something right you have all these
things that you probably could make an
effort to be like hey what's going on
with this I know I don't show up but I
want to start showing up and a lot of
the time the people who run these things
are like oh thank God yeah we could use
more people
um but a lot of the time like by being
Parts being a part of these communities
we learned so much about ourselves
because of the role that we play in
these sub communities
and I think this is just part of our
human nature like we need other people
to remind us of Who We Are
and if we don't like and people are
invaluable they provide invaluable
feedback too
right like if you say something and
jokes just continually don't land right
and you're seeing and people look at you
like you have some sort of problem
like maybe that's an indication that
your comic material needs some work
maybe you need to learn how to listen
instead of just monologue
like me